you know we're surrounded by this huge
Dome that is an LCD screen that they
play the backgrounds onto which is
connected to the camera it reads the
iris on the camera it reads the movement
of the camera so as the camera moves the
perspective of the background will move
and you shoot against it and you don't
have to put it on afterwards it's there
but for us it means you're surrounded by
what feels like the real thing
[Music]
if you're in the desert well there's a
desert set on the floor and everything
but everywhere you look around you and
above you is the desert and it feels
really real but if you're flying through
space in your spaceship
space is scutting past you the stars are
flying by you it feels much more
realistic it's much more fun